hi my name is Calvin Giacometti and
today we'll talk about applications
about understanding speech with a
foreign language
hello everyone my name is Carlo
Giacometti and I work in the signal and
audio processing team and today I will
talk about speech so there's a very
pretentious title that says
understanding speech so maybe there is a
bit over reaching but I will tell you
what you can do with the Volcom language
to use them some machine understanding
of speech signals so I'll show several
example applications one will be keyword
spotting then we'll have some special
cognition some speaker recognition and
some gender classification so let's
start with keyword spotting one is it
this problem we have a collection of
recordings and in each of these audio
signals a person speaks I did a digit
from 0 to 9 well this is sorry about
that
so we're using the spoken digit that
commands that set that we have in our
source system and this these are some
examples of data for several exeter
exeter so we want to develop something
that takes us an input these audio
signals and outputs which digit is
spoken we make sure that speakers in a
training so we don't cheat the classes
of this problem as I said 0 to 9 and if
we look at the relations of these
signals they are all between 0.5 seconds
and one side which is very convenient in
the fact that the network will always
have this uniform kind of input so we
have several strategies that we could
follow we could go the completely
automated machine learning strategy by
using the classify function first of all
we need to massage the ring
a little bit to make it in a format that
makes classify happier we define a net
encoder which is comes firms all about
the objects into mattresses in this case
of a fixed dimension and hopefully this
will capture most of the important
information and then we just throw this
data inside classified with minimal
effort and this minimum iPhone result
already gives us a 70% accuracy on the
test test and this as I said was really
zero now if we want to put a little bit
more effort into it we could consider
defining a neural network and since
we're talking about audio which is
inherently a variable-length problem we
will use a recurrent network that is
based on gated recurrent layers stuff
that works very well with sequences
essentially we will use the same encoder
we will compute the M FCC features to
feed into the network so as again the
encoder is defined you can see the
network is really simple it just
involves two gated recurrent layers and
then some basic machinery to do the
classification between the various
digits I will actually turn it here and
hopefully everything will work and yep
this is just running in real-time on my
machine my machine does not narrow
Network does not exploit a graphics card
on my machine so everything is computed
on the CPU and even with that the
training speed for the simple example is
quite impressive to respect to what we
could have had in the previous versions
and after the training is done we can
compute the performance and as you can
see we jump from a 70% accuracy to a
more than 90% accuracy
one interesting thing that we could do
is some feature exception using this
network so instead of classifying we
want to from an audio signal you want to
extract a single vector that is
semantically meaningful to what the
input was so what we do is we chop some
chopped out some layers from our network
that we originally defined that we have
trained as you can see I took out the
last layers that did the classification
so this produces a vector of 64 elements
independent of the length of the input
and we can use feature space plot to
visualize all of the testing data so
official space plot does it takes these
lengths 64 vector for each input and
tries to place them in a two dimensional
space in a meaningful way as you can see
it does cluster signals with different
numbers in the popular way they are : in
addition to the labels they have color
each so this way we can extract some
information that is not just the
classification some vector that encodes
semantic information about the signal so
we can now move on to a much more
complicated task speech recognition in
version 12 we are introducing as you
might have seen from given demo we are
introducing the speech recognizer
function and what does it do I mean as
advertised it takes right then perfect
timing and tries to figure out what we
spoken the operation is comprising two
paths first there is an acoustic model
that transforms the other thing in a
sequence of probability distributions
of a characters and then there is a
decoding step that might or might not
involve a language model language model
takes their output from the acoustic
model and tries to correct it with some
knowledge about the language by the way
this at the moment only suppose English
speech it's no it will not immediately
support any other one which in version
12 at least so we can actually look at
the internals of this function the
acoustic matron model is the deep speech
to network that was released by Baidu
and we are using the splitter network
because they managed to train it on an
internal data set that they have but it
has almost 10,000 hours of label speech
so what goes into this the audio object
is encoded in a spectrogram this is how
decoded spectrum might look like for our
specific signal and then is fed into the
network the network has a few
convolutional layers at the beginning
that are followed by some custom gated
recurrent units that do most of the work
so here we go this is the own network
that just gums the spectrum as an input
and it outputs reach time frame the
probability distribution over all
characters so we can look actually this
result I mean bigger so this is the
probability per each character over time
of our signal this
result is then processed by a CTC beam
search so what we're trying to do is
we're trying to find what is the most
likely sequence of characters given this
acoustic model so the number of possible
sequences of course there are a lot of
times that is very high so this is the
same combinatorial hell we want to avoid
that so what happens at every step the
decoder figures out all of the possible
continuation and then keeps only the
first end and these get passed at the
next step so at each step we only
compute a limited number of options and
you can see whoops you can see these are
on the vertical axis you have the
decoding step and on the horizontal axis
you have the various choices of decoding
is pair those times so you can see how
they evolve and then this is the final
result by the acoustic model decoded by
the CTC beam search know if you remember
the result that I gave speech recognizer
was much better than this sentence that
is because this output is then filtered
by a language model that takes into
account normally about the language that
we spoken so again what this is a
modified being searched decoder
so we have our probabilities out of the
acoustic model the dimensions there are
at the second dimension of this matrix
is 29 this is the number of classes that
we are considering which have the
characters from this alphabet plus a
blank character so our language model is
based on a character level language
model that we stained on data sets of
transcripts of TED Talks we are planning
to upgrade this
it will probably be upgraded before
version 12 but at the moment this is
what we have this is a character level
language model there is based on current
layers some surgery is required to
massage this network into something that
is more efficient in battle valuations
for the beam such computations and some
more massaging is necessary for the
output of this network to be included in
that computation so we end up with this
object here that contains all of the the
language model itself and all of the
information that is necessary for the
language model to play nicely with the
beam search and Here I am exposing very
very much internal code that is of
course liable to be a leader modified
etc etc and at each step what happens is
the CDC beam search has the probability
from the acoustic model and it computes
what is the probability of that sequence
according to the language model and
these two probabilities are mixed
together using a mixing function that
will be controlled by this mixer level
parameter and this will give us a score
of the result that will take into
account both the acoustic and the
language model so you can see these are
the first four top results and you can
see that though that spelling mistake
that the main main is now corrected by
our language model so another thing that
this this is more of an application
example this will not have any
associated function in 12 but this is an
example of what they both on
language can achieve combining the audio
processing capabilities with the neural
network capabilities so I want to show a
different problem
speaker recognition so we don't want to
understand what was spoken but we want
to figure out who was the speaker to
tackle this problem of course as we
don't projects we need to start from a
data set here the Vox Salim - data set
was used this is a collection of about 1
million utterances by about 6,000
speakers and the structure of this data
set is pretty simple it it has that each
file there's associated some information
about who the speaker was and what
gender he or she was and the labels of
course identity of these people some
example here the task is very well
defined it's very simple classification
the classes are mutually exclusive of
course there can be only one speaker of
that file so the network that we chose
to use is actually network as general
used for image processing and as the
mobile net version 2 network
so this accepts only a fixed size input
so how do we solve the problem of
variable length input that is I mean
these signals so we compute our feature
which in this case will be the male
spectrum this produces one single big
matrix what we do is we chop it up in
fixed sized chunks without overlapping
and then map the network over each of
these chunks so let's see how that works
so this is the encoder this is the
result from the encoder
as you can see this as to fixed size
mattresses that will then be fed to the
main network and this is the main
network as I said fixed size input and
then a single vector of length about
6000 which will give us our
classification so we can apply it just a
second about that we will apply it on
our own each of our frames and then we
don't really want a result of valuable
lines so we need to aggregate those all
over the time dimension so we take the
mean and this is and this is what
happens here we take the mean of the
result and then we feed this the mean of
the result to the decoder which will
then give us define our classification
so what we have done we have classified
we have a network that takes an input
and tells you which celebrity you might
sound only useless right not
particularly interesting but the what
the network learn is how to
differentiate voices and this is a
really powerful skill so what we can do
we can go back to what we did before
with our digit recognition we take the
network we chop the last part and we
then produce a meaningful semantic and
bad leg of the input signal so I will go
back to the spoken digital command and
as I said before this data set does have
some information about who the speaker
was again I will import the network
and as before if we just use the network
this will just give us the probability
that a son like son but what we can do
we can grab we can grab just the first
layer of this network which is the
mobile net in this case that we the
restrain and produce something that
doesn't classify anything but produces
this semantically meaningful embedding
and if we applied that to our digit data
set so if we apply that to our digit
data set we can see that in the feature
of space the various speakers are very
much separated so this network now we
can we can see that this network
understands information about different
voices and then codes is able to encode
this information about voices in one
single fixed length vector so have
another example that does essentially
the same on a different data set so I
will not go completely through it I will
just show you the result so I can show
you the last example this is by the way
this is the same structure I just show
you
it's just applied to the test subsection
of the Box Salib data set the network
again has not seen these examples during
the training and it still manages to
separate quite effectively difference
because this data set is what you would
get in the wild rather then very much
curated does that like the spoken digits
one so the last application I'm going to
show you is gender classification so as
I mentioned before in the Box Salib data
set we do have
information about the gender of the
speaker so what we did in this last
example is just again some massaging of
the data where the label is not who the
speaker what is anymore but what the
gender of the speaker was now one
approach is to take an undervalued
Network and start the training from
scratch hoping that network but we do
have a network that as I said understand
something about voice so we use that
network as we did in the previous
examples as feature extractor and we can
build on this pre trained voice related
feature extractor to just go in this
case just classified we're not even
bothering defining a new neural network
so what happens for the data data is
then encoded by our time network and
then classified using just classified
without any valid whistles just minimal
effort going into this and even with
this minimal effort we managed to get
96% accuracy on the test set classifying
the gender of the speaker and you can
compute this on whichever audio signal
okay and this concludes I guess the
collection of example that I want to
show you thank you very much this is the
team that worked on I won't thank
specifically Rebecca thinking there were
other ones that did most of the work
signal image and signal processing team
thank you very much
you